all right well the win is taking Las
Vegas on a new Quest audiences can now
immerse themselves in Awakening the
Resort's new headlining show here's
Rocky with an inside look
the win is Awakening Las Vegas to a new
era of entertainment
Awakening is many different things it's
a call to action it's Vegas coming out
of the dark it's a new Fresh vibrant
strong original approach to live
entertainment
and that includes the custom designed
360 degree theater executive producer
Bernie human says it's extraordinary
Rick gray and his team has taken the
theater all the way to the ground and
and rebuilt it he built the original
theater for Lay rev the theater is state
of the art amazing technology in every
way shape and form you know the theater
is an experience in and of itself the
wind Awakening team is all about
delivering something different to Vegas
entertainment historically we all know
most of the shows in Las Vegas have been
based on visual feasts and sensory
overload and this particular show is
really light and dark
and it brings you really to a place
that's a universal place of
understanding that together we are all
born light Darkness narrated by two-time
Academy Award winner Anthony Hopkins The
Awakening story invites audiences on a
quest to reunite two lost lovers there's
myth there's drama music technology and
fashion soyon has Forward Thinking and
this is fashion forward and there's
never been a show that I can remember in
Vegas or or on the west end of London or
even on Broadway that has anything even
similar to the costuming in this show I
think it really enriches the experience
you know on a different level that you
wouldn't normally expect complimenting
the performances of Awakening 60 cast
members this cast is the best cast I've
had the privilege of being involved in
live entertainment in Las Vegas for a
very long time you know this cast is the
best that I've seen so far and I'm
really proud of that and most of
importantly Bernie says audiences will
leave entertained and empowered they've
seen something different than they've
ever seen before and that they're
entertained and that it's uplifting and
that they leave because they feel
empowered and they take the experience
with them and that nurtures itself and
then they bring it back with them the
next time they come and see Awakening
wait Awakening premiered last night and
you can see the show Tuesday through
Saturday well moving on to